You've mastered scientific notation for getting these right. If you had trouble
with one or two of them, that's okay too. For this number, the a value would
need to be 2.389, and I would have to move this decimal five places to the
right, to get back to my original number. This number is also really large, so
we know we're going to need a positive power. If I think about moving this
decimal 12 places to the right, I end up with my original number. The last one,
the decimal point needs to come after the 7. So if it were after the 7, I would
need a negative exponent to move this decimal back to the left 7 spaces, and I'd
get this number. And we now multiplying by a negative power 10 really divides
this by a power of 10, so our number becomes smaller.